[Music]  who are you are you only the legend or  are you the truth behind the legend all  right all right I'm here we believe in  you  now tell me remember the deeds you have  performed the labors you have  accomplished you cannot deny what you  are man cannot escape his fate now who's  that for an adventurer no matter how far  you go the Beast will follow  [Music]  okay I know what I'm doing you said no  violence this is over a local camp okay  your name is a rallying cry we all know  your legend I'm a regular everyday guy  family man I only want to be a husband  and a father  my communes I would do anything to  protect my family the people need him  save these people and restore order to  this world more than seven itself  let's get to work you want out to let up  [Music]  [Music]  let's go  [Applause]  [Music]